hey guys it's angelica from max tech and
happy end of 2020.
this disappointing year is finally
coming to a close and to honor that
i want to talk about the most
disappointing apple fails of the year
some of these you guys can instantly
name some you may not know
and others you might not even agree with
and yes this video does include
m1 max the first fail is the smart case
apple's airpods max was their final
product of 2020
and in our honest opinion they killed it
on the headphones but
the case was their worst product of the
year first off
it looks like a bra which has spawned
many memes but
more than that usability sucks since
it's required to put the headphones into
low power mode quickly
and it has slits along the edges and an
exposed headband which makes scuffs and
scratches a concern
the next disappointment is apple still
sticking to lightning ports
we know that they will soon be switching
over to portless iphones and usb-c
everywhere else
so why wouldn't they just switch over
now especially on the airpods max
if you bought these headphones you're
going to be keeping them for a long time
so why would apple stick to lightning
when in a year or two
everything is going to be usbc or
portless and
you're going to be stuck needing to keep
a lightning cable just to charge your
headphones
the next failure is a big one earlier
this year apple released new intel
macbook airs with much faster graphics
and powerful quad-core cpus
they had both a heatsink and a fan but
they did not connect
the fan to the heatsink this was
absolutely ridiculous
and made for very hot and loud running
machines that throttle
so much the quad cores weren't really
worth it
now we do have a theory we think apple
really wanted to make the macbook air
fanless and counted on intel's 10th gen
cpus running cool
but they didn't so instead of
redesigning everything they threw in a
fan to draw more air in
but of course that wasn't enough and it
led to massive throttling issues
and super annoying fans even when
browsing the web and doing simple zoom
calls
now the next disappointment involves m1
max
first the m1 macbook only natively
supports one external display
which hasn't been a limitation with max
for like almost 10 years
now and this alone caused people to go
for an intel macbook instead
or wait for a future apple silicon model
second the new m1 mac mini for some
reason
only has two thunderbolt ports or
previously
the intel mini came with four ports and
guess what the m1 mini actually supports
four ports let me explain owc dug deep
into figuring out the reason behind the
lack of the extra ports
and they discovered that apple is
actually using two separate thunderbolt
controllers just like the old mini which
has four ports
and m1 actually supports thunderbolt 4
but apple couldn't call them that
because they only support one display
apple could have technically given the
m1 for thunderbolt ports but they
decided to limit it and that's a huge
fail
because we can no longer get 10 gigabit
ethernet as well
meaning that max can't connect to our
server and those two ports are full from
his display and our qnap
moving on to the next one let's talk
about the iphone 12 pro max
when apple first announced the best
cameras only coming on the pro max
quite a few people including max bought
it just for that
but it turned out to be a bit of a
disappointment
the main camera is only slightly better
but the two and a half times
lens looks worse than the two times on
the pro more often than not
that's because the aperture went from f
2.0 to f 2.2 in order to achieve the two
and a half times
zoom and that means that it takes in
less light because of that
photos in lower light look worse with
more noise and more motion blur as well
portrait mode photos suffer even more
since they require more light
so in many cases max and vadim have been
using the main camera
way more than before it seems like apple
caved into pressure from other competing
smartphone companies having more zoom
even though it didn't really help them
quality wise another fail this year is
apple no longer including charging
bricks
this was a big deal when everyone first
found out because the new iphone 12s
include a lightning to usb-c cable
so if you don't already have a usb-c
power adapter you need to buy one
separately from apple for 19.
now this isn't really a huge fail by
itself since other companies have been
either raising their 5g
phone prices which apple didn't and with
that they are now following suit and no
longer including charging bricks with
their upcoming phones
even after making fun of them where it
gets worse is magsafe charging requires
this new brick
as well for full speeds but not
including it
at 39 dollars it's a bummer but not a
huge deal
but when spending 130 dollars for the
max save duo
not getting the 19 brick that's required
is a huge fail
speaking of charging apple's new max
save charger itself
is the next disappointment on the list
at first we were really excited
for it because apple advertised it as
having 15 watt wireless charging
which was long awaited but that was a
massive exaggeration
in reality max safe only charges at 15
watts for the first 10
of battery after that it slows way down
to less than half the speed at about 6
watts
and even worse if you have an older
iphone or an android
it maxes out at 3 watts less than half
the speed of that typical wireless qi
chargers that can be bought for 15 bucks
which is
really disappointing on the topic of mac
safe the new max safe wallets are also
a fail when we first heard about it we
were pretty excited
it seemed like a great product for
people that only need to carry around a
few cards
and you could even use it in place of a
phone case if you wanted to
but it was a big letdown for most
because the magnets in the wallet are
very weak
so it constantly slips off when you're
putting it into your pocket for instance
and that's honestly pretty scary always
having to risk it falling off somewhere
losing your cards
the 12 mini is the only phone we can
recommend it for
because it fits perfectly and doesn't
slip off but
apple could have fixed this by using
stronger magnets the next fail of the
year is the iconic
thousand dollar stand for the mac pro
now the fail actually isn't the pricing
of the stain itself
since it's machined out of a solid block
of aluminum and you could easily adjust
the display
by just using one finger but it was the
way the apple announced it
just watch for yourself
hey guys it's max here it looks like
that was such
a fail for apple that angelica has tried
to upload this video
twice and modified that clip and apple
keeps blocking it from youtube and not
even allowing us
to post our video so basically what
happened here
is that apple showed off the xdr they
showed off
the stand and then when they gave the
price the whole crowd
kind of had this collective grunt of
disappointment
for a thousand dollar stand and that
does
once again prove our point probably even
more so
that this stand from apple was a massive
fail or at least the way they handled it
everyone was shocked by the pricing
which is understandable
but that wouldn't have happened if apple
just said the display is six thousand
dollars and if you don't want the stand
then you get a thousand dollars off the
last failure of the year is the mac
pro and not because it's a bad product
but just because of how fast it's aged
and not in the way most expected like
older pci slots or cpu sockets but
because of apple's own
m1 processors making the beast seem
outdated now sure
a mac mini won't replace the crazy
high-end configs or expandability of the
mac pro
but we've already seen many people say
that they're going to wait for an m1 mac
pro instead
and max himself is having trouble
selling his mac pro at a good discount
with two buyers backing out because of
how powerful apple and one max are once
apple releases the new apple silicon mac
pro
the prices of these will drop
dramatically if you want to know more
about what it'll offer check out
william's detailed video right over
there
click the button above to subscribe
thank you guys for watching and thank
you for helping us reach 500 000
subscribers this year
happy new year and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]
happy new year all right i'm done
freaking done screw this